the credits have rolled the OG Guardians
are gone and Peter Quill's got Lawns
tomorrow but is this really the last
we've seen of Star-Lord warning spoilers
ahead Say It Ain't So as of the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 the
original Guardians team is no more
Rocket Raccoon is leading a brand new
team with many of his fellow Rascals
heading off to do their own thing Gamora
has returned to the ravages nebula and
dragster bringing up a band of children
on a newly rebuilt nowhere while mantis
is off on her own with a giant Squad of
space lugs what a bunch of a-holes but
where did I leave the guardian's Leader
Peter Quill well in a beautifully sweet
way volume 3 leaves pizza right back
where we found him having come to accept
that the woman he loved is no longer the
woman he loved Peter chooses to return
to Earth and reunite with his grandpa
his last remaining Terran relative it's
here where you think the HotShots Hero's
tenure might come to an end and yet in
the film's final moments we see the
message the legendary Star-Lord will
return so it seems that Chris Pratt's
character has been hooked on feeling
since 2014 we'll be coming back for more
but how in a recent interview with
Esquire Middle East James Gunn suggested
we may not have seen the last of the
Guardians franchise he said there could
be more Guardians movies but it won't be
with this group if the series does start
up again Gunn won't be handling it until
likely be too busy running the DC
Universe to consider returning to Marvel
Studios that doesn't mean Star-Lord
won't pay the MCU another visit in the
future though and since many future
entries will take place in the
franchise's cosmic corner it's possible
that price may already have had talks to
return there is one condition however
there has to be a good reason for Peter
to return speaking to Games Radar Pratt
initially seemed reticent about coming
back referring to gun he said it would
be strange to continue Peter's story
without James he's done such a massive
old job in the first three films we
really found the voice of Peter Quill
together and without him obviously I
would never have had this opportunity
Pratt further clarified that his
enthusiasm in coming back to the MCU
would rely on the manner of star-lord's
return he added I don't want to be
cynical in the approach and if that's
the case I just wouldn't do it at all so
maybe down the road if something makes
sense I would do it but it would really
have to check a lot of the right boxes
of course considering the ending of the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 it's
possible that Pratt's comeback may come
sooner than anyone expected the only
question is and what points could he
actually return Peter Quill might have
settled back in his hometown but given
the current state of the MCU it's
possible that Earth's Mightiest Heroes
have got their eyes on him the next
Marvel project set for release a secret
Invasion on Disney plus which will see
Nick Fury come back to earth before
joining the franchise's next big screen
Adventure the Marvels Cosmic
it wouldn't be a totally wild idea to
see Peter Pop Up in either project given
they involve a great deal of alien
activity but there's no mention of him
so far at this point it would actually
be a massive surprise if it turns out
Kevin feige and the rest of Marvel has
kept a Star-Lord appearance Under Wraps
but that doesn't mean he won't show up
in some of the mcu's future tense pole
releases let's not forget for example
that two Avengers movies the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars are due to enter
production soon either of which could
see Peter pulled into The Fray to assist
the Avengers now that he's back on his
home turf it only makes sense that he
would lend a hand to protect the Earth
should the opportunity arise after all
someone needs to choose the tunes
foreign